landing a role in a superhero movie
comes with more than just a nice
paycheck and a steady work opportunity
afters are now expected to get in
superhuman shape for action roles and
Margot Robbie as Harley Quinn is no
exception here's how she got into havoc
wreaking shape of course Margot Robbie
is fully dedicated to playing Harley
Quinn now but she originally got the
role without even having to convince
anyone she wanted it the actors told MTV
News that the team behind Suicide Squad
approached her with the role offering
her the part without even having to
audition I actually got offered this one
I didn't lose audition which was a real
step up as an actor when you can get
offered things as it turns out the
producers were captivated by Robbie's
performance alongside Will Smith in the
2015 movie focus Smith was already
locked in to play Deadshot and Suicide
Squad wanted to recreate that connection
when they cast their Harley Quinn I
guess they knew that will and I worked
well together so that was a given we
didn't have to do like chemistry roots
or anything like that the studio's
gamble paid off and while the overall
reviews for Suicide Squad were in less
than enthusiastic the dynamic between
Smith and Robbie was a consistent high
point of the film you're my friend to
stay evil doll face Margot Robbie is
already in pretty great shape thanks to
working out four or five times a week
for an hour each session according to
Hollywood personal trainer Andy Hecker
to get in fighting shape for her comic
book movie however she ramped that up to
three hours per day as part of a ballet
based fitness program that Hecker
operates Robbie worked out in three hour
blocks nearly every day for three weeks
while filming Suicide Squad pecker told
People magazine that the focus on
Hartley's body and her skimpy costumes
pushed Robbie to work out that much
harder according to Hecker there's a
scene in Suicide Squad where she changes
clothes in front of a bunch of dudes
so her abs needed to be impeccable and
in those tiny shorts Harley wears her
but was constantly on display the parts
of Robbie's body that were on screen for
most of Suicide Squad became the focus
of her tailored workouts Hecker came up
with an exercise routine that would
transform Robbie from a glamorous
starlet into the tough and acrobatic
Harley Quinn according to hacker Margot
wanted to
lean out and tone up she's already
slender but we wanted to make her a
little stronger to achieve these goals
most of Robby's workout regimen
consisted of non bulking cardio
exercises like ballet jumps as a former
dancer who runs a ballet training
program pecker told people that the
jumps ballet dancers perform are quote
surprisingly the most challenging form
of cardio I have ever come across
but despite the relative difficulty of
the exercises pecker said that Robbie
rarely ever faltered in her commitment
to the routine Hecker compared Robbie to
a machine when she spoke to the Los
Angeles Times the actress's workouts
apparently resembled dance marathons
where other clients of Hecker's would
steadily throw in the towel while Robbie
kept at it relentlessly pecker shared
that other people would try the workout
along with us but she kept going when
other people were dropping off it's so
challenging to keep up that level of
intensity but she powered through it
pecker also ran the actress through a
weightlifting regimen intended to tone
her butt thighs and legs she spoke of
Robbie's workout on a granular level in
the lead-up to suicide squads release
telling publications the exact types of
exercises Robbie went through while
trying to embody Harley Quinn
she said that they went for a lower
number of reps with more weight a focus
on Form and engaging the correct muscle
groups in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter pecker explained she
had to look sexy and strong we do lower
reps so 20 leg lifts with that ankle
weight on and then take a break to move
on to the other leg to do another 20
making sure her glutes were doing it and
not her hamstrings if that robotic
intensity is making you feel like you'll
never be able to attain a form like
Margot Robbie's don't worry
while Hecker painted a picture of the
actress as an ultra dedicated workhorse
in the gym
Robbie herself revealed that she is far
from disciplined when it comes to her
diet in an interview with Emirates woman
Robbie admitted that she can't handle
calorie cutting diets and that cutting
delicious and fatty foods from her life
makes her miserable I'm not good at
doing moderation I can't just have a
salad every day and a half a glass of
wine every second day I can't do it
Robbie told the publication that our
diet largely consisted of beer fries and
burgers which she burned off in the gym
she added
that she has a rather unhealthy way of
cutting weight quickly if a rule calls
for it saying if I have to get in a
bikini then I'll eat carrot sticks for
three days I'm one extreme or the other
successfully pushing to get a standalone
Harley Quinn movie made meant that
Robbie had to get back into Suicide
Squad shape in which she was able to
perform most of her own stunts
according to Suicide Squad co-producer
Andy Horowitz Margaret doesn't 97% of
her stunts in this movie she embraced
everything we throw at her she makes it
her own and does it better than we could
have ever assumed it was gonna be
however when it came to revisiting
Harley for birds of prey Robbie said
many of the stunts in the new film were
actually too dangerous to take on
there's a lot of really cool stunts in
the birds of prey movie quite a few of
them I couldn't do because they were
just too risky that's not to say that
Robbie slacked off in comparison to her
work for Suicide Squad though in
addition to her regular workouts
Robbie trained to roller-skate ahead of
birds of prey after already learning to
ice-skate for her role in a Tonya photos
of Robbie training and shooting in
rollerskates circulated on comic book
blogs ahead of the movie's release
revealing that prey will be based on a
later version of Harley Quinn modeled
after roller derby players the roller
skating Harley Quinn comes from the new
52 reboot in the DC Universe which
remodeled many characters with a hard
refresh of 52 titles even a newish
character like Quinn was not immune from
the mandate the most recent version of
Quinn has been completely removed from
the Joker as she finally split with the
Clown Prince of Crime for good with her
newfound independence Quinn's
motivations have also shifted where
before most of her actions could be
explained as working for mr. J the newly
single Quinn is considerably less
villainous she's become a sort of anti
heroic vigilante toeing the line between
criminal and superhero while attempting
to hold her home of Coney Island
together the new Quinn is in the mold of
wisecracking weirdos with murky morals
like deadpool and screenwriter Christina
Hudson even cited the Merc with a mouth
when she talked about her early talks
with Margot Robbie around the film
Robbie's dedication to the character is
bound to translate to the big screen
once again as it did in Suicide Squad
and
fitting that birds of praise reviews are
a big improvement over the reaction to
Suicide Squad it's likely that we will
be seeing Robbie as a ripped Harley
Quinn for years to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]